wait-wait-wait-wait fans not completes
without me Gordo's back now this really
is what dreams are made of
Adam Lamberg aka Gordo is officially
joining the reboot of Disney pluses
Lizzie McGuire it's a dream come true
Hilary Duff dropped the news in a
surprise video obviously the show would
not be the same without her family so
I'm so excited the Jake Thomas is bad
thing not and Hallie Todd it's bad
playing Joe and Bobby carrying my dad
Sam wait wait wait wait Sam's not
complete without me Gordo's back this is
what dreams are made told ya what dreams
are made of we're having a lot of fun
and it's it just feels very surreal now
we still don't know if Miranda will be
back in the mix but it feels like it's
only a matter of time until that
announcement comes after all LaLanne who
plays Miranda recently got a text from
Adam if you'll remember the three of
them were BFFs in the original version
of the show I have two of the best
friends in the whole entire world
you know Gordon and I were just saying
the same but there was always something
between Gordo and Lizzie maybe
sometime we could all hey Lizzie
Hillary confirmed earlier this year that
the series starts with Lizzie engaged
but it's not - Gordo though it could be
- Ethan crafts Lizzie's longtime crush
now I was kind of hoping that Lizzie
would help out this time I love the way
even says my name chance that Lizzie's
engaged to Ethan um I don't maybe you
could be helping the writers right now
with some like future plans and then
cave back there right yeah absolutely
yes yes but no she's not currently
engaged to Ethan craft someone else like
a new a new person like in his place
well you said that Lizzie's engaged she
um
I have no idea what you're talking about
I'm so bad at playing Chloe I'm like an
open book okay so she was a little coy
about that but she did spill a major
deets on animated Lizzie when et was
with her earlier this month guess I'll
be going now
animated Lizzie does she have an updated
look she's gonna say the same yeah which
i think is the right thing to be right
it's like that pink top it's so iconic
and I pat form flip flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip flops I
don't know if anyone knows those I think
she's really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show Hillary also said
this now that she's in her 30s what kind
of struggles do we see her go through I
think that was part of the draw for me
of coming back was like the struggles
that I feel of being a 30 year old and
obviously we're in very different places
I'm a mother I'm in a serious
relationship and she has a lot of those
things she has gained a lot of
confidence and she has a really cool
career and you know she's still I think
she's still going to be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet you know it's the same Lizzie but
she's an adult and I
for me that's a little challenging
shooting because I have that muscle
memory of that like awkward frantic kind
of teenager and so making choices RAM
like playing the bait she wouldn't say
that she's 30 she can't do that now like
it's it's definitely fun and a little
challenging and also so familiar at the
same time Lizzie McGuire is set to
premiere on Disney Plus next year and I
am obviously very excited for all the
latest on Hilary slash Lizzie stick with
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]